foreign
let's go to San Diego California now
where Mark is on the line Mark how can
we help
hey how you guys doing we're having a
blast what's up
hey so yeah I'm um I've been dating this
girl for about nine months and we kind
of started talking about finances and
money
and she has about three hundred thousand
dollars in debt
um she had a PhD in um Pharmacy
so she's a pharmacy manager making
around I think you're on a hundred
thousand dollars a year
and you know that was kind of a shock to
me because I
um I have no debt I have good credit
score I have an emergency time I have
enough money to actually purchase a home
right now if I want to
um I have a thriving business
and we talked about it I kind of said
okay well you know if in the future you
know because we're not going to share
expenses or finances until we're married
I would be happy to
support the household when we're married
while you're having your income mostly
go to the debt so we can kind of work on
it together
and that seemed like a good plan and
then
a couple weeks later she kind of brought
up you know the understanding of like oh
you know I have
um
a brother that's uh special needs that
you know might need financial assistance
in the future you know her parents are
taking care of him right now
so I'm trying to figure out okay what
would my responsibility do you meant to
kind of said you know there might even
be a tune so we might need to take care
of my mom hypothetically but probably
not in the future financially and I'm
getting concerned because I feel like
the expectations are quickly
kind of increasing on me to be able to
provide and
I don't know and I'm like
it's causing anxiety for me in a
relationship basically no question when
you marry somebody you marry their
family too
yeah right
and so I don't think it's out of Bounds
at all to take care of an aging parent I
don't think it's out of Bounds at all to
have a plan to take care of a special
needs brother and sister I think that's
beautiful
what you have to ask yourself is
is knowing that loving her comes with
also
taking helping support family
is that a life you want to buy into
that's the choice here don't don't over
complicate it
okay in fact it's I think it's beautiful
that she is that articulate up front
really I I read that a little
differently okay did you read it
differently than that Mark did it feel
presumptuous out of nowhere or did you
feel like it was an extension like John
saying I could be reading it wrong
um I don't know I mean okay hang on
we're gonna we're gonna dig in I want to
dig into this one yeah yeah hang on the
line Mark we're gonna go to a break here
I'm gonna put you on hold and we get
back uh I could be wrong there's some
onions here no no I might be I I just
wonder if he doesn't feel like whoa that
was a little fast when you came at me
with Mom and the brother and John I want
you to repeat your thought there and
that led us to what is he feeling but
you you said as we were going to break
what did you say ultimately
um it's not out of bounds for someone to
say hey I've got a brother with special
needs that I anticipate having to take
care of down the road right and by the
way I'm hoping that
um or might be that one day one of my
parents is gonna have to come live with
us if the other one were to pass away
um and so I want to have space in our
relationship for that because it's
probably gonna happen
um I don't think that's out of Bounds at
all in fact I was saying I don't like
the fact that she's this clear this soon
but something is a little bit off and I
just felt like Mark maybe you called us
because it and not to say that she's got
any uh untoward uh ideas but it felt
like maybe it caught you off guard and
and maybe you're like oh how should I
react to this how are you feeling about
this
yeah I guess it's difficult for me is
it's kind of like um like I'm a planner
like I like to understand the
expectation that's put on me I'm good at
like solving problems and many
minimizing risk and to me it's almost
like okay so like if maybe I should
already be starting to fund you know for
the brother or for I don't know her
extended family or something all right
so let me let me push a little bit more
do you feel uncomfortable did you feel
uncomfortable when she brought up her
mom and helping out with her Mom's
finances I understand the brother who
cannot help himself am I am I reading
that correctly
yes but what about the mom did that make
you feel like why should I have I'm just
curious and maybe you didn't but I just
want to know
the yeah so if I'm being truthful the
reason why is because
she has kind of told me how her mom is
kind of passive aggressive and can be
very controlling and my interaction with
her haven't been bad but it hasn't been
great so I think obviously if I had more
love and connection with her over time
then of course I'd want to help out a
loved one all right so now I'm glad I
dug John now now how do you react to
that so here's what it sounds like it
sounds like you have a picture in your
mind of what you getting married is
going to look like
yeah and you can prep for that by
getting all the funds in the right place
getting all the genes in the right
drawer and getting all the cars in the
right place in the garage
and yeah what I would tell you is this
all relationships a hundred percent of
them whether you've been married one
week or 50 years all relationships are a
risk
yeah you open yourself up to somebody
could hurt you and the beauty of a
marriage is somebody says I'm going to
open up myself to you fully
and you are going to spend the rest of
your life loving me and I'm going to do
the same back to you and the scary part
about it is it only works if both people
jump with both feet we get a lot of
flack here for telling people to share
bank accounts to talk every week about
their schedules and things like that no
I got to be me bro dude it's not gonna
work you both got to be all in and that
means you have to say I'm gonna plan I'm
going to dream but we're going to plan
and dream together and that is a skill
set that you don't have and that's okay
very few people have that going into
marriage
um yeah you just have to decide you want
to learn that but like okay I don't feel
right about this so John I want you to
keep going keep going keep going I think
you're okay planning for the brother I
don't think you're okay I don't think
you've bought into the fact that you
even need to support mom and I quite
frankly sitting here go I'm not sure I'm
signing up for that
am I onto something yeah so here's the
deal are you ready to marry this woman
are you just talking about it
um I think I'm ready
I think I'm ready I mean I I love her
and I want to marry her and I
I don't yeah I don't know yeah but I
know you don't because let me put it
this way
if
she had not brought up taking care of
Mom
how would you have answered that
question
um come on man I think it would have
answered a little bit differently
I think I need to be able to have the
conversation just with her in the
morning I think so too uh John I'm gonna
throw it back to you on because I've
appreciate everything you said yeah but
I slight I go I don't think he has to to
put himself out there no he didn't have
to here's the thing I think he's got to
tell her okay so here's what I think
Mark I think John I'm gonna pass it back
to you I would like to see him sit down
with her and go okay here's what I'm
feeling about this yes I'd like to know
your Mom's finances I want to know the
whole picture if we're talking about
you're expecting me to maybe help I want
to know the whole enchilada what's
Mama's Finance situation and see what we
what the risk would be and how old is
Mama right and can mama get her acting
gear and and I'll support mom if she
does this this and this and she needs a
place to stay yes but as far as letting
her run up debt and be irresponsible
with money when I don't agree with that
I'm not buying into that I guess Mark
that's what I'm feeling underneath the
surface am I right
I completely agree isn't it kind of like
just in general if I'm lending money to
family members or that I'm crossing that
threshold that is kind of my
responsibility to have an understanding
of like yeah
so hey so here's where you got to be
real careful Mark
um
my guess is and I could be out to lunch
your girlfriend slash shoot your fiance
slash shoot your wife
made a blanket statement of some sort
that said come hell or high water I'm
going to take care of my mom P I need
you to know that about me I'm a kid
who's not gonna let my mom be on the
street
and in your mind you're a planner and
you went to okay well what's the budget
for that gonna be and what's her 401
401K look like right and so what ends up
happening is you have a picture of take
care of Mom which is this is a problem
to solve and she has a picture of I'm
gonna take care of Mom which is a person
to love and what happens is y'all are
having a fight that shouldn't have to
happen because you're having two
separate conversations so I enter that
conversation and say I love the fact
that I love a woman
who wants to take care of her mom
yeah in my head here's what this looks
like I start thinking about how much is
this going to cost are we going to have
space we have to buy a different house
we're gonna have to move communities or
we get all those different nuts and
bolts and now you're in a very different
conversation which isn't are we going to
love Mom it is how are we going to do
this and you can say I am all about
loving you all about honoring your mom
I'm not in the business of loaning
people money yep they can live in a room
in my house we can get a mother-in-law
Suite on top of the garage here is a
core principle of mine and if she comes
back and says we're going to loan our
money to our family
now you've got a values issue right
that's less of a mathematical formula
issue or a risk issue that is a no I
loan money I don't loan money and now
you're talking about future issues in
your marriage which is why you date
right is this making sense
yeah because I kind of wonder what kind
of well I know why she reacted this way
because out of the moment of emotion she
said I know that you're big on not
loaning money
um so she is aware of my general values
and boundaries
um but then like you were saying with
make the loving and the planning and
how do you do it together with someone
that you'd be one with in a marriage and
her family be my family
um
just kind of complicates here's uh
here's what I'm gonna do um this is like
a pre-engagement gift we're gonna send
you one year of FPU I want you to watch
all the lesson videos with your
girlfriend and if her mom will join you
that'd be great too I want you to watch
them together and it will give her some
context of where you're coming from and
if nothing else it will give you all a
common language for which to build your
relationship or to make the hard
decision to
call it all right thanks for the call
Mark this is the Ramsey Show